Was meinst du, das ist der beste Akzent, den du imitieren kannst?
Russisch.
Russisch? Ja.
Ja, wirklich? Ja.
Geh mir mal Russisch.
Ja, das ist so auf Zurufend schwierig. Ich muss ein bisschen reinkommen mit dem einen Wort, das ich kenne.
Da, da, ja, wir, Juri, wir, bra, na, wichtig ist, also, kurz mal vom Akzent, laufen wir schon, ja, dann spare ich mir diese kleine Eindote, nein, wichtig ist folgendes, wenn ihr den Akzent nachmachen wollt, kommen wir zu Stefan Tietze Akzent Masterclass, also ihr braucht einen Namen in dieser Sprache, es wird mir spontan so etwas einfallen wie Yuri im Russischen oder Francesco im Finnischen.
Und dann braucht ihr noch ein Wort, das ihr kennt aus der Sprache, um so ein bisschen in diesen Sprachrhythmus reinkommen, diese Sprachmelodie reinzukommen. Leider ist es bei mir im Russischen das Wort da, was nicht so hilft. Ja, was auch ein deutsches Wort ist. Ja, aber da, da. Ja, Juri, wir müssen nach Moskau, um Wodka zu trinken.
Und so merkt er, ganz natürlich kommt er in diesen Fluss rein. Ja, das klingt mega gut.
Wladivostok, Wladivostok, Wurst, Wurst, Wurst, Trink.
Oh, Juri, wir trinken Wodka in Wladivostok okay. Herzlich willkommen zum Podcast-Sufo mit Stefan Tizrikowski. Wie mehr mit Stefan. Und mit mir. Stefan hat heute Morgen gesagt, ich muss dringend, dringend neue Akzente und Dialekte lernen. Also man davon abgesehen, dass sein Sozialleben komplett in Ruinen liegt, er bald keinen Job mehr hat und seine Frisur langsam Ausmasse annimmt, die nicht mehr akzeptabel sind. Dennoch, seine Priorität sind erstmal Akzente. Ich habe mich auch im Fitnessstudio angemeldet, aber Priorität ist erstmal Akzentcoach. So, dann habe ich überlegt, warum zum Akzentcoach gehen, wenn ich selber einer sein kann und habe mir deshalb krude Theorien angeeignet. Call out the middle man, einfach sofort zum Lehrer werden, sofort zum Fitnessstudio Besitzer werden, nicht erst hingehen, sondern sagen, ich will mein eigenes Fitnessstudio haben. Ich glaube, ich kann gut lehren. Und ich glaube, dass es auf eine Art hilft, quasi einem das selber beizubringen. Da ist Viola, hallo Viola, man muss ganz kurz für die Aufnahmesituation sagen, dass wir... Wir wurden aus unserem Studio geworfen. Dass wir jetzt aber in der Maske sitzen, uns komplett geschminkt haben, Flotin hat komplett alles voll, Kajal, Lippenstift. Und wir sitzen einfach in so einer Art Kommentatorenkabine und starren auf den Hof. Genau, wir haben ein großes Fenster vor uns und starren auf dem Hof, wir sitzen nebeneinander. Wir sehen es nicht an und wir sehen auf dem Hof der BTF, wo gerade jetzt, es ist 9.30 Uhr morgens, Oh, die ganzen Leute kommen jetzt an. jetzt gerade hier ankommen und es ist sehr interessant, wie die verschiedenen Leute hier sich unbeobachtet fühlen. Aber du meinst, du kannst gut lehren. Dann bring mir das mal bei. Ich bin dir mein... Jetzt bring mir das mal bei. Italienisch, okay? Ja, das ist fies. Ich will mir was aussuchen können. Gut, alles klar. Bring mir mal bei, warum diese These The Medium is the Message. Bring mir das mal bei. Du hast ja einen Kommunikationsbachelor. Ich dachte, wir sind immer noch in unserer Sprachakzenttheorie. Das ist ja jetzt mehr gemein. Gut, alles klar. Bringen wir das mal bei. Warum ist das Medium die Message? Naja, je nachdem, wo du etwas guckst oder wie du etwas konsumierst, sagen wir mal so, wenn man jemandem zuhört, der spricht, wie viel Prozent, glaubst du, kommt es auf den Inhalt an und wie viel Prozent kommt es darauf an, wie er etwas sagt und mit welcher Mimik und Gestik er das verbindet? Du wirst erstaunt sein. 50-50. 80-20 pro Mimik und Gestik. Heißt, was er sagt, ist im Prinzip völlig egal. So, wenn du jetzt etwas auf dem Fernseher anschaust, ist das Medium the message. Aber ob ich es jetzt auf dem Fernseher anschaue oder auf YouTube, warum ist das ein Unterschied? Weil die ganzen Handlungen, diese Vorlesung habe gefehlt, aber diese ganzen Handlungen, die du damit verbindest, die ganzen Gewohnheiten, die du damit verknüpft, dieses ganze, was da sonst so rumläuft, dieses ganze, das Rauschen, was da um diese Sendung, die du gerade guckst, ist, was kommt danach, was war da vor, wo steht das Ganze, das verbindest du halt mehr mit dem Inhalt und verbindest du mehr. Einerseits so YouTube konsumierst. Ich bin absolut überzeugt. Gut, ich bin absolut überzeugt. Vielen Dank, war komplett falsch, aber man muss sagen, es kommt viel darüber an, wie man selbstbewusst etwas sagt. Probier mal was bei. Was möchtest du denn? Ich darf es mir aussuchen.
Und zwar, du bringst mir das Prinzip von Diesel bei. Diesel wird im Unterschied zu Benzin nicht durch eine Zündkerze entzündet, sondern durch Druck entzündet. Der Teil des Diesels, der in dem Motor gelagert wird, der sozusagen mit seiner Sprengkraft den Motor antreiben soll, wird erst ganz eng zusammengedrückt und dadurch entzündet er sich. Und dann geht es auch los. Das heißt, deswegen kann es teilweise, wenn es ganz kalt ist, sein, dass ein Dieselmotor weniger gut anspringt als ein Benzinmotor, weil er sich erst über diese Temperatur hinaus erwärmen können muss, wohingegen bei Benzin einfach eine Zündkerze einen Funken erzeugt und dann das Benzin entflammt, egal wie warm es ist. Ihr habt mich nicht überzeugt, ich habe das Wort Automotor gewartet, es kam es nicht. Gut, das stimmt, ja. Ich war es auch manchmal in der Schule, wenn manche Wörter nicht kamen, von denen du wusstest, dass sie damit irgendwie in Verbindung gebracht haben und du diesen letzten Funken Hoffnung an dich selber, dass du irgendwas von diesem Thema weißt, dass das nicht kam. Du möchtest eigentlich auch eher deine eigene Sicht bestätigen und nicht was Neues lernen. Du gehst eigentlich in die Schule, um zu wissen, ja, Magnete hat ja was mit Elektros zu tun. Und solange das Wort Elektros nicht kommt, sage ich, ja, wir haben keine Ahnung davon, ich steige aus. Aber du sagst gerade, ich bin geschminkt, es war tatsächlich so, wir hatten gestern gedreht und ich war, kann man ja vielleicht ein bisschen Spoiler, eine Profession, die zumindest klischeehafterweise Kajal trägt.
Und Kajal ist furchtbar abzuschminken, also das ist so dieser Liedstrich, so ganz schrecklich, auf der ekelhaftesten Stelle des Körpers, wirklich direkt auf dem Augenlid, auf der Kante des Augenlids, malt man da rum, wo überhaupt gar keine Farbe jemals sein soll, wo dein ganzer Körper sagt, ja hey, alles nur vom Auge weglassen. Das ist eine dumme Idee, aber auch, dass man das reinmalt. Man hat so viele Mechanismen, der Körper hat so viele Mechanismen, um alles von den Augen wegzuhalten. Augenbrauen, Augenglieder, Tränenflüssigkeit, Wimpern, alles nur, alles aus dem, nimmst, gibt's am Fuß, nimm's am Bein, gibt's der Nase, aber noch nicht den Augen, alles, der ganze Körper sträubt sich dagegen, dass du irgendwas im Auge hast und dann kommt jemand und malt der da mit so einem Pinsel. Ins Auge ja fast rein, das ist schrecklich. Du siehst es ja dann nicht, ironischerweise, obwohl es bei den Augen ist und dann malen die halt so da drin rum so und dann klappen die das so rum. Das ist ganz eklig. Das ist ganz furchtbar. Und deswegen hatte ich nach dem Dreh auch nicht so das Verlangen, mir das so gut abzuwaschen, weil du musst du halt da so rumreiben an der Kante. Und deswegen bin ich so und dann war ich tatsächlich, kam Matthias an bei einem Campus Radio zu Gast und habe ein Interview gegeben und hatte noch einen halben Kajal an einfach. Und es ist einfach interessant, weil man denkt sich immer, wie muss man aussehen, damit andere Leute es kommentieren. Also wenn ich jetzt einfach Lippenstift tragen würde, würden Leute einfach das völlig hinnehmen und sagen so, cool, oder würden sie ab einem gewissen Punkt sagen, jetzt pass mal auf, jetzt müssen wir drüber sprechen. Spannend, ich glaube die Kurve ist auch anders bei Menschen, die dich kennen und bei Menschen, die dich nicht kennen. Die Toleranzgrenze bei fremden Menschen ist wesentlich höher. Wesentlich, wesentlich höher. Sehr oft so, wenn ich hier ins Büro komme und ein Kilo mehr wiege, weil ich gestern mal bei KFC geradet habe, dann heißt es sofort so Fetty, Fetty, Fettson. Er wird direkt auf so einen Thron platziert und dann stellt er erstmal so einen Roast. Gäste werden eingeladen, Überraschungsgäste. Und hier ist dein Vater, Bilder, wie du früher auch sagst. Dunking Donuts presents The Fat Roast. Genau. Aber was ist passiert? Fühl uns mal durch den Moment des Aufeinandertreffens bei dem Campus Radio. Es war so, wir haben uns getroffen und es war irgendwie eine ganze Belegschaft von Leuten. Vier Leute haben mich empfangen und haben mich dann zum Studio gelaufen. Und nach der Begrüßung hatte man sich relativ wenig zu sagen. Deswegen dachte ich mir einfach, ich spreche das einfach direkt an, um einfach Gespräch zu füllen. Um den Damm zu brechen. Deswegen hat es auch ganz gut funktioniert. Mir waren sehr nette Leute, hat alles gut funktioniert. Aber ja, man sieht aber jetzt gerade auch noch so ein bisschen, dass du es noch hast, dieses Kajal-Ding. Und es ist so ein bisschen so, als ob man denkt einfach, du, das ist eine schöne experimentelle Nacht. Das ist, glaube ich, primär, als was man denkt, wenn man das sieht. Man freut sich ein bisschen für dich. Tausend und eine Nacht Nacht. Schön für Florentin, dass er es endlich geschafft hat, ein bisschen zu sich zu stehen und mal was zu erleben. Ja, vor allem interessant ist, wenn es noch so halb dran ist, dann ist das wie so ein Schatten. Dann kann man das gar nicht so richtig nachvollziehen, sondern man denkt sich nur so, weil Frauen werden einfach hübscher und Männer werden ein bisschen merkwürdig. Irgendwie so einfach so, hm, komisch. Auch ein bisschen hübscher, aber auf so eine, aber auf keine männliche Art natürlich. Ja, so eine, ich bin verwirrt. Ja, genau. Meine Erektion sagt ja, aber mein Körper sagt nein. Und die Gesellschaft sagt auch nein, mit dem Ausrufezeichen. Und alle anderen sagen, wer bist du, ich habe da mit dem Konflikt relativ wenig zu spät. Wollen wir mal den Hof beschreiben? Ich meine, es ist doch wunderbar. Also, man muss sich vorstellen, hier ist gerade niemand. Wir starren auf einen leeren Hof hinaus. Also, das ist natürlich so eine U-Form von uns ausgesehen, Rechtsgebäude, geradeaus Gebäude, Linksgebäude, und es stehen viele Autos auf dem Hof, mehr als man eigentlich denkt, wenn man die Gebäude so anguckt. Und ich finde, dafür, dass es gerade so eine Uhrzeit erreicht ist, wo viele Leute zur Arbeit kommen müssen, kommt es relativ wenig auf den Hof. Der Hof ist ja an sich furchtbar. Ich finde den Hof toll. Der Hof ist wunderschön, weil man sich auskennt. Aber das Schlimmste, also wenn ich irgendwo eingeladen werde und er ist so, ja, sei um 12 Uhr da, einfach auf den Hof und dann links und dann weißt du schon, ja, forget it. Forget it einfach. Ich finde gar nichts. Hof ist einfach so, der Hof ist das moderne Bermuda-Dreieck. Du weisst, du gehst darin verloren, keine Chance, weil niemand versteht, wie Höfe funktionieren. Da gibt es dann auch so, ja, Adresse 24b. Und du weisst schon, sofort wenn ein Buchstahl bei der Adresse steht, weisst du, forget it. 24p, na komm, jetzt wird es gleich alles. 24 Sonnenbrillen-Emoji und du weißt sofort, okay, wir planen mal eine Stunde mehr ein, weil forget it. Das ist zum Beispiel eine interessante Entwicklung im Bereich des Gefängnisses. Früher waren ja Gefängnisse so Kerker, so Löcher im Boden, wo man einfach Leute reingeworfen hat, die dann versauert sind, die wurden versteckt. Aber irgendwann wurden Gefängnisse statt eines geschlossenen Systems ein sehr offenes System, wie zum Beispiel dieser große Gefängnishof, wo ein großer Turm in der Mitte ist, wo dann ein Wärter oben im Turm drin sitzt und alle sieht. Ein Wärter nur? Oder zwei Wärter. Je nachdem, ich kenne mich jetzt nicht mit den genauen Bestimmungen der Gefängnisse. Wie heute ist es mit dem Beton, dass ein Wärder ist da oben. Naja, im Vergleich zu den Gefangenen wenig, will ich damit sagen. So, das heißt, wo du früher die Gefangenen versteckt hast, sind jetzt die Gefangenen sehr sichtbar und sind dadurch fast noch in ihrer Privatsphäre mehr beraubt. Ja, das stimmt. Und auch in gewisser Weise Gefangener, weil wenn du alleine in deinem Loch sitzt, dann denkst du dir, ja gut, ich kann zumindest hier machen, was ich will und ich habe hier meine Privatsphäre. Aber wenn du auf so einem Hof oder so, in dem Turm ist vielleicht gar niemand, aber das weißt du ja nicht, weil du siehst ja nichts. Ich glaube, das ist ein Wärter, exakt ein Wärter. Ja, aber das ist jetzt tatsächlich nicht der Punkt, auf den ich hinaus möchte, sondern einfach die Tatsache, dass je offener ein Raum ist, desto geschlossener ist er in einer gewissen Sicht, weil du weniger frei bist. Und genau so funktionieren Höfe. Du bist orientierungslos. Das ist einsteigend. Ich meine, Trendforschung vor und den Willen, ich glaube so, dass es irgendwann zu einer Art Transparenz kommt. Also, dass man, wie man angefangen hat, so wichtige politische Gebäude wie den Reichstag zum Beispiel, auch Gläsern zu gestalten vorne, dass man, um Transparenz auszustrahlen, dass man diesen Trend weiterführt und irgendwann sagt, man hat gar nicht mehr, weil es ist auch immer noch geschlossen in Form eines, es ist ein Betonbau mit wenig Einlass, Lichteinlass, mit sehr viel Gitter, also sehr wenig nach draußen, dass man da in Richtung Glas geht, sogar in Richtung offen denkt, um das noch weiter zu beeinflussen? Kann sein. Also ich glaube, Gefängnisse folgen immer den Fitnessstudios und Fitnessstudios werden auch immer mehr gläsern, immer mehr mit Glas.
Und immer mehr Saunen, meinst du auch. Auf jeden Fall. Ja, und immer mehr so Proteinshakes auch auf jeden Fall. Deswegen kann auf jeden Fall sein, ich habe so Fußfesseln habe ich letztens mich mit beschäftigt. Und das ist ja auch verrückt, weil dann ist ja sozusagen ein ganzes Leben Gefängnis, weil die wissen immer, wo du bist, da ist halt so ein GPS-Sender drin, die wissen
immer, wo du bist und du darfst halt dann nicht irgendwie die Grenze
verlassen oder so. Das heißt, ist das
besser oder schlechter? Ja, das ist bausam.
Einerseits, weiss ich nicht, ist es
auch so wichtig, dass jemand weiss, wo du bist?
Ganz kurze Frage, wie oft habe ich dir im letzten
Monat gesagt, wie gern ich im Gefängnis
wäre? Bestimmt dreimal, oder? Ja, ist das tatsächlich
so, ja. Ist das bedrückend?
Nee, ich finde es nämlich toll, also diese, weil ich finde, du hast im Gefängnis paradoxerweise die krasseste Freiheit, weil du die geringsten Opportunitätskosten hast. Du kannst, ich kann in meinem Leben, wenn ich abends mittlerweile vorm Fernseher sitze, denke ich mir, soll ich einen coolen Podcast hören, soll ich eine coole Serie gucken, soll ich einen coolen Film gucken, soll ich Fernsehen gucken, wo vielleicht mal was Gutes läuft? Also hast du im Gefängnis auch? Nein. Also angenommen, du bist in dem Gefängnis, wo du medialen Zugang hast. Übertragst du nicht eins zu eins, aber was ich damit meine ist, du kannst halt so viel machen gerade, dass du eine beängstigende Freiheit hast, wo du natürlich aber nicht frei bist, weil du natürlich dich auch entscheiden musst. Diese Entscheidungsfreiheit ist natürlich auch eine. Die hast du aber im Gefängnis theoretisch auch. Du kannst nur wesentlich weniger machen. Heißt, du kannst deine Freiheit im Prinzip besser ausleben, weil du die Sachen, die frei sind, da kannst du dich freier entscheiden. Aber ist es nicht erfahrungsgemäß so, dass je mehr Zeit man hat, was zu machen, desto weniger macht man letztendlich? Also dieses klassische, ah, in den Ferien mache ich dies und dies und dies und das und man nimmt sich wahnsinnig viel vor und am Ende macht man gar nichts, weil man den ganzen Tag irgendwie nur Gilmore Girls schaut.
Jetzt gehst du aber davon aus, dass man sechs Wochen im Gefängnis sitzt und nicht 18 Jahre.
Und ich glaube, da ändert sich das.
Ich habe mir das auch schon gedacht, aber dann habe ich mir gedacht, so Hitler zum Beispiel hat es ja vorgemacht, bestes Beispiel, hat ja im Gefängnis meinen Kampf geschrieben, mega gut genutzte Zeit, super gut, hat da eigentlich schon alles geplant und hat dann sich, also der perfekte Beispiel von Reintegration hat sich da Gedanken gemacht, Das ist ein sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr planen, weiter voraus planen, so mein Kampf ist ja schon viel angedeutet, so ein bisschen geteasert, was dann so tatsächlich passiert ist. dass kein Buch so viel über Menschen aussagt wie Mein Kampf. Er schafft es schon sehr gut, sich, also man findet sehr viel Hitler in dem Buch wieder. Ja, absolut. Es ist das ehrlichste Buch. Ich finde nicht so viel, sagen wir mal, so Sebastian Fitzek im Seelenbrecher wieder. Ich finde mehr Hitler in Mein Kampf wieder. Ja, und er ist aus dem Gefängnis rausgekommen, war ein neuer Mensch, war verwandelt, hat aus seinen Fehlern gelernt. Leider wird es dann oft manchmal schlimmer als davor. Wow, okay, jetzt kommt ein Auto direkt vor uns. Okay. Alles klar, kann fahren sein. Holy shit, ein Audi mit einer ganz merkwürdigen Farbe. Wie nennst du diese Farbe? Oh, das ist nicht schlecht. So ein dunkles Lila. Olive, oh nee, gar nicht. Nee, es ist Olive plus Lila plus Dunkelblau plus Schwarz. Plus Ultramarienblau. Oh, er winkt nicht zurück. Wir können ja mal ganz kurz gucken, welche Mitarbeiter winken und nicht.
Wir haben jetzt hier einen Vertreter der Postproduktion.
Ja, aber der Postproduktionschef sogar.
Oh, nicht gewunken.
Nicht gewunken, unangenehm, ist aber auch unangenehm.
Ich kann mir das auch vorstellen, wie man uns so sieht hier.
Und er weiß, wir sehen ihn jetzt die ganze Zeit.
Aber das meine ich mit Höhen.
Oh, er spürt die Blick in seinem Rücken.
Wenn du nicht weißt, wo du hin musst und du biegst irgendwie ein in so einer Einfahrt und bist auf einem Hof
und du siehst ganz viele Fenster und du weißt, jetzt stehe ich unter Beobachtung und die Person, mit der ich mich treffe, wartet vielleicht auf mich und steht am Fenster und beobachtet, wie ich erstmal komplett wie so eine Ameise erstmal dumm im Kreis rumlaufe. Furchtbar. Gegenüber von uns tatsächlich die Teppichwäscherei, wo Leute immer kommen, das ist unser tägliches Anblick, Leute kommen, holen einen grossen Teppich aus ihrem Auto raus. Das ist doch kein Geschäft. Wenn du jetzt anfängst, also wenn es ein Teppich, dieser Laden, der eröffnet eine ganz neue Welt an Läden. Wenn es eine Teppichwäscherei gibt, wo ist dann die Autoreifenwäscherei? Türenwäscherei. Wo ist die Türenwäscherei? Habt ihr schon mal eine Tür gereinigt? Nein. Wo ist die Gardinenwäscherei? Wo ist die, vor allem, ey, kann ich nicht meinen Teppich einfach eine Reinigung geben?
Die sagen doch auch nicht ein Nein, bitte gehen Sie sofort raus.
Das ist doch einfach eine Geldwäsche.
Die haben doch irgendwie so ein Drogenbusiness hier in Köln am Laufen.
Und das ist deren Geldwäsche.
Ob da manchmal so Leichen drin sind in den Teppichen?
Ja, wie bei Gus Fring.
Das ist meine große Theorie, der hat auch diese Wäscherei, wo Walt und Jesse unten dann die ganzen Drogen brauen. Und das ist doch genau das gleiche hier. Braun. Der uncoolste Begriff von Drogen herstellen, brauen. Das ist auch, wenn du zum Drogenboss kommst. Oh, da kommt Katja auf ihrem Fahrrad, wenn du zum Drogenboss kommst und sagst, hallo, ich würde gerne für dich Drogen brauen. Ah, halt. Ersten Menschenwinken. Sehr umsichtig. Ja, aber es ist auch gut, wenn man jemandem, der gerade schnell Fahrrad fährt
und dann rechts hinter
einem zugewunken wird.
Das heißt, er muss ganz rechts nach hinten gucken
und eine Hand vom Lenker nehmen. Das heißt, vielleicht schaffen wir es
auch einen der Fahrradfahrer hier zu Sturz
zu bringen. Aber lustige Geschichte, ich war ja hier
für mein Bewerbungsgespräch war ich ja hier
und da hieß es dann... Wie lange ist das her?
Drei Jahre. Und dann hieß es plötzlich
ja, im Innenhof Leindeggerstrasse 27, bitte links halten. Ah ja. So, jetzt ist links halten gut ausgedrückt, weil man kommt hier seitlich, also stellt euch das mal als großes, als Rechteck vor, diesen ganzen Hof. Ich glaube, das tun die Leute bereits, sich einen Hof als Rechteck vorstellen. N ein quadrat sein ja ich glaube nicht dass sich ein Stern vorgestellt wir gehen unten wir gehen unten rechts wenn ihr euch das länglich vorstellt wir gehen unten wir posten bild wir gehen unten rechts rein jetzt heißt links halten ist perfekt weil du hältst dich einfach links an der wand an der langen seite der wand ja und kommst dann irgendwann automatisch zur Tür wo auch jemand stand der mich begrüßt offenen Armen. Toll. Eigentlich müsste man schreiben diagonal, eigentlich müsste man sagen Hofdiagonal. Auf der anderen Seite von der Sieg. Ja, aber auf der anderen Seite ist schwierig, weil was meinst du mit anders? Meinst du seitlich oder parallel ist ganz merkwürdig. Am besten für eine Zeichnung. Ey, Orientierung ist echt das Schlimmste der Welt. Hast du mal einen Kompass besessen? Ja, als Kind habe ich einen Kompass besessen. Ich war ja auch Abonnent des Mickey-Maus-Magazins, da war auch in jeder dritten Ausgabe ein Kompass drin oder so ein Teleskop oder sowas in der Richtung. Von daher, ja, habe ich einen Kompass besessen. Aber tatsächlich, mein guter Freund von mir hat mal einen für mich unglaublichen Satz gesagt, und zwar dann irgendwie, wir waren mit dem Kompass nicht verstanden. Wir dachten einfach, mit einem Kompass kann man alles finden. Und dann war es so, wo ich gesagt habe, okay, ich verstecke mich im Wald und du musst mich mit dem Kompass suchen. Und dann ist mein Freund dem Kompass im Wald gelaufen und muss relativ schnell bemerkt haben, dass ihm der Kompass nicht hilft. Und dann ist er so durch die Gegend gelaufen und irgendwann bin ich dann rausgekommen und habe gesagt, was ist los? Und dann hat er auf diesen Kompass gestarrt und gesagt, ich bin immer genau zwischen Norden, Osten, Süden und Westen. Ich bin immer genau dazwischen. Wo ich mir dachte so, wow! Jeder Mensch ist zu jedem Zeitpunkt immer genau dazwischen Norden. Ja, immer, aber exakt genau. Er ist nie mal mehr im Süden oder mehr im Osten, sondern er ist genau in der Mitte. Ich dachte, er sagt am Ende des Tages, Flotin, ich habe mich zwar nicht gefunden, aber ich bin sehr, sehr gerade nach Norden gelaufen. Ja. So was. Ich hatte einen schönen Tag. Ja, und ihr beide geht so fröhlich und zufrieden mit dem Tag und euren Errungenschaften, des Wissens, nach Hause, essen, Butterbrote, geht schön einschlafen. Das ist genau wie wenn du sagst, ich bin gerade genau zwischen links und rechts. Aber genau, ich bin exakt zwischen links und rechts. Aber das ist immer so das Traurigste, das habe ich auch bei meinem Zivildienst manchmal beobachtet, wenn Kinder Verstecken gespielt haben, es ist immer traurig,
wenn es ein Kind gibt, der nicht
gesucht wird. Der immer so, ah Miriam
gefunden, ah Alex gefunden und
Fabi sitzt den Rest des Tages
in der Schokolade. Ist auch meistens das Kind, was man als Betreuer
wahrscheinlich auch am ehesten vergisst
und was dann einfach dann auch während
der Butterbrotzeit einfach so in der Ecke
hockte. Ey, das ist auch so ein Ding
so, was man, wir haben in der Schule hat mal jemand jemand einen Streich gespielt, oder was heißt Streich? Mord. Da hat es geregnet, und dann waren wir alle im Klassenzimmer und dann haben ein paar so ihre Regenschirme, dann die zwei Mädchen, die immer einen Regenschirm dabei hatten. Alle anderen Kinder wurden einfach nass. Boah, wer kennt sie nicht. Die hatten dann einen Regenschirm dabei. Regenschirm ist echtes Objekt, das ich wahrscheinlich am meisten verachte, wo ich mir denke, ich werde niemals einen Regenschirm besitzen, egal. Auf jeden Fall lagen dann diese zwei grossen Regenschirmer ausgebreitet im Klassenzimmer und ein Schüler hat sich vor der Unterrichtsstunde einfach hinter dem, jetzt laufen wieder zwei Leute auf uns zu, die nicht zurückwinken wollen, und ein Schüler hat sich dann hinter diesem Regenschirm versteckt, einfach so zusammengekauert, hinter dem Regenschirm und die Lehrerin hat die gesamte Stunde gemacht und so zehn Minuten vor Ende ist er einfach aufgestanden, hat sich gestreckt und sich auf seinen Platz gesetzt. Und die Lehrerin hat ihn auch angeschaut, so, ja, cool, cool Story, Bro, einfach ... Nicht schlecht. Geiler, heißer Scheiss.
Auch so ein Prank, der einfach so ein Sinnvakuum erzeugt.
So ein ... ja, okay.
Aber wo wir gerade über Kompos gesprochen haben,
bei Flug der Karibik 1 gibt es einen Satz, wo ich immer dachte,
oh, Film, ich bin cleverer als du.
Und Spoiler-Alert, ich war nicht cleverer als der Film.
Und zwar kam es dann zu diesem Satz, wo Jack Sparrow gefangen genommen wird und jemand sagt, wow, sie haben einen Säbel, der könnte aus Holz sein, sie haben einen Kompass, der nicht nach Norden zeigt und irgendwas anderes. Also ich dachte mir, hm, du brauchst, wenn man keinen Kompass, der nach Norden zeigt, solange der nach Westen, Osten und Süden zeigt, weißt du ja automatisch, wenn Norden ist.
Ciao! Und bin hier aus dem Kino gegangen.
Arme an der Herr!
Naja, fand ich sehr clever in dem Moment, rückblickend ein bisschen doof.
Wahrscheinlich hat er einfach irgendwo anders hingezogen die ganze Zeit.
Es gab auch nur diesen Nord-File und der hat halt irgendwo hingezogen.
Hast du eine grobe Ahnung, wo Norden ist?
Ähm, ja, auf einer Karte. Nee, aber jetzt hier.
Ja, also und zwar, ich glaube, wir gucken nach Süden, weil also diese ganze Sonne-Sache kann ich mir nicht mehr erinnern. Der Lidl ist im Süden. Dieser ganze Sinnspruch, der im Osten geht die Sonne auf, im Westen nimmt sie ihren Lauf, im Süden.
Hab ich nie verstanden. Naja, weil vor allem ist es kein Sinnspruch, weil du kannst alles miteinander tauschen und es ist genauso gut singbar. Du kannst jedes einzelne Himmelsrichtung... Du kannst sagen, im Westen geht die Sonne auf, im Norden nimmt sie ihren Lauf, im Süden wird sie untergehen, im Osten ist sie nie zu sehen. Du kannst es... Also was ist ein Sinnspruch, wenn er die dich mitgibt, wenn er die dich das essentielle mitgibt? Sehr, sehr gut. Naja, und ich weiß, von wo die Linie kommt, die U-Bahn-Linie, mit der ich komme. Die kommt nämlich aus Osten. Und dann kommt sie von Osten und dann gehe ich quasi Richtung Süden hierher und wir gucken in die Richtung, in die ich gehe. Heißt, wir müssen nach Süden gucken. Und wir können es nachprüfen. Es ist auch immer, wenn irgendjemand irgendwas beschreibt und dann sagt so, ja, im Süden das und das, und im Süden davon ist bei mir immer so nicht den Hauch eine Ahnung, was das jetzt bedeuten soll. Oh, Lea kommt auf uns zu. Sie hat noch gute 50 Meter, wir winken mal die gesamten 50 Meter lang. Sie hat schon gesehen, aber sie tut so. Ah, sie tut so, als würde sie auf ihr Handy gucken. Ah, plötzlich hat sie uns entdeckt. Morgen, Lea. Hallo. Aber ganz, ganz interessante Sache, die du gerade angesprochen hast. Schlechte Sinnsprüche ist auch tatsächlich eine Nemesis von mir. Und zum Beispiel... Tatsächlich, wir gucken, na ja, fast Richtung Süden. Hat seine Kompass-App gerade rausgeholt. Wir gucken in Richtung 145 Grad Süden. Ansonsten als Sinnspruch immer, der Lidl ist im Süden. Lidl ist im Süden. Elby Süden. Der tatsächliche Sinnspruch bei uns gab es immer, ich weiß nicht, ob das überall ist, aber in Bayern war es zumindest so, dass es, wenn es um Bierkultur ging, man natürlich sehr stolz war auf die guten Biere Bayerns. Und dass ein berüchtigt billiges Bier war Oettinger. Oettinger ist, glaube ich, so das billigste Bier, was man sich kaufen kann. Und dann gab es immer so diesen Spruch, willst du dich billig besaufen, musst du Oettinger kaufen. Und die Leute lagen am Boden vor Lachen und ha ha ha. Und ich war immer der Einzige, wenn man sich jetzt so ein Bild vorstellt, ich bin so in der Bildmitte, alle lachen und bewegen sich und ich bin ganz still und stark und sag so, wow, wow, wow, Leute, ihr lacht gerade und habt Spaß, aber ihr habt gerade falschen Spaß, weil man kann in diesem Spruch jedes andere Bier, willst du dich billig besaufen, musst du Erdinger kaufen. Das funktioniert so nicht. Du musst einen Reim auf Oettinger finden, nicht auf kaufen. Und das hilft mir nicht, wenn ich irgendwann mal wissen will, wie ich mich billig besaufen muss, muss ich kaufen. Ja, was denn? Trotzdem reibt sich Saufen auf Kaufen. Es funktioniert nicht. Das Wort ist austauschbar. Und dein Gegenbeispiel, du hast natürlich, ich weiss, du bist ein progressives Mitglied der Gemeinde, du hast natürlich dann ein Gegenbeispiel geliefert und dein Gegenbeispiel, um ein Merkspruch für Oettinger, damit man sich merken konnte, ist das billigste Bier, war Es ist so billig, trink immer mehr, mehr, mehr von Oettinger.
Erdinger.
Ja.
Paulaner.
Das ist ja, Ött ist auch einfach eine beschissene Silbe, wo du nichts draus machen kannst. Ich meine nur, Leute, wenn ihr euch Sinssprüche überlegt, dann bitte achtet darauf, dass sie nicht austauschbar sind mit jeder anderen Bedeutung, die es gibt. Dann ist es nur ein sinnvoller Sinsspruch Idee? Immer wenn ich Bettina Böttinger sehe, wünsche ich, ich würde mich billig besaufen mit Oettinger. Ja, aber das Wort billig ist ja jetzt auch nicht. Also, dass sich Oettinger alkoholisiert, ist ja nicht...
Na gut, aber dann willst du dich halt billig besaufen.
Das ist jetzt halt die Connection,
die du machen musst. Das ist mein
Learning.
So, mittlerweile hat sich jemand
Rauchen vor das Finster gestellt. Moment mal,
hey! Ja, vor allem
äh, so wir machen das
jetzt mal auf.
Herzlich willkommen, herzlich willkommen das Podcast-Ufo. Unser Vape-Boy Sebastian wurde mit einer Zigarette erwischt. Was ist denn das? Deine Lunge tanzt gerade Samba. Du kannst doch nicht einfach jetzt gleichzeitig normal rauchen und dann auch noch vapen. Das Problem ist, dass ich herausgefunden habe, dass der Kiosk bei mir um die Ecke einzelne Zigaretten... Das hast du erzählt, stimmt. Und jetzt bin ich wieder total gehuckt. Ich bin irgendwann morgens raus, war total müde, wollte mir eigentlich nur eine Mate schnappen, bin rein, hatte die Mate schon in der Hand, habe sie bezahlt, bin raus und hat so diese Zigaretten irgendwie so, diese ganze Wand voller wunderschöner Zigaretten in verschiedensten. Voller toter Embryos und verschimmelter Beine gesehen. Genau, schlecht geschminkter, blau geschminkter Kompasen. Ich fand mich, wessen Baby ist das? Welche Eltern haben gesagt,
macht ruhig mein Baby auf der Zigarettenpackung
als Abschreckbeispiel. Aber
das Einzige, was mich immer,
was mich zum Rauchen bringt, sind eigentlich diese tollen
Marken. Dann sehe ich da
American Spirit und so und denke mir
wow, und das sieht alles so cool aus.
Deswegen glaube ich, kann man sich dann diese Zigaretten
zusammenstellen wie so eine bunte Tüte, kann man so sagen,
ein Lucky Strike. Das ist eine total gute Idee. Also es ist offiziell verboten, Zigaretten zusammenstellen wie so eine bunte Tüte, kann man so sagen, ein Lucky Strike.
Das ist eine total gute Idee. Also es ist offiziell verboten, Zigaretten einzeln zu verkaufen, also habe ich gehört und zumindest soll es glaube ich in Köln so sein, ich weiß nicht, ob es irgendwie überall so ist, aber es gibt Kiosk, die das machen. Oh, und ein Ding, das habe ich dann noch versucht bei dem Kiosk hier vorne, Zendower-Strasse, Ecke, und habe auch gesagt, so hier, verkauft jetzt Zigaretten einzeln und der Typ meinte so, ja, ja, kein Problem, machen wir und gib mir zwei Zigaretten und sag so einen Euro bitte. Moment mal kurz, du holst jetzt da 50 Cent pro Zigarette oder was? Und er so, ja, ja, klar, ich so, hey, du wirst das doch eigentlich gar nicht verkaufen, dann auch noch so ein Wucher, das geht ja gar nicht. Na ja, und im Grunde hat er gesagt, muss ja nicht kaufen. Was habe ich gemacht? Schwach wie ich bin. Fünf Auge gegeben. Nicht schlecht. Cool. Ja, cool. Viel Erfolg auf deiner weiteren Reise in den Saar. In den Tod. Tschüss. Oh, da kommt Ina auf uns zu. Die hat zwei Schüsseln Züssigkeiten in der Hand. Hallo! Schüttelt lachlos im Kopf.
Wow, die Schüssel nenne ich aber.
Moment, es gibt nichts Fieseres,
als jemand über langem Zeitraum zuzuwinken.
Es ist unglaublich unangenehm.
Aber es macht sehr viel Spaß hier an der Stelle.
Aber es stimmt, überlegt euch bessere Sinssprüche.
Falls euch etwas einfällt zu Oettinger.
Also ganz toll, diese Art,
also ich habe echt teilweise, ich hatte eine Zeit, wo ich echt damit gekämpfen musste, nicht mit dem Rauchen anzufangen, natürlich nicht, weil ich war auch viel zu jung zu dem Zeitpunkt, aber ich fand das halt so toll, diese Marken, diese verschiedene Marken, und dann, mein Vater hat damals HB geraucht, so, und dann fand ich das cool irgendwie, warum, also was ist das für ein Charakter, dass er zu diesem HB greift, weil die schmecken ja offensichtlich alle gleich so, weil da sind ja im Prinzip oft die gleichen Dinge drin, zu einem großen Anteil. Das ist ein bisschen wie Wasser, kann ich mir vorstellen, ohne die Erfahrung zu haben, aber mein Onkel und meine Tante, die haben Camel geraucht. Da dachte ich mir, okay, die sind offensichtlich ein bisschen anders. Und warum machen die das? Und das fand ich so faszinierend, diese verschiedenen schönen Verpackungen, dass ich das auch gerne machen wollte. Und dann gab es halt irgendwann diese Kaugummi-Zigaretten. Und die haben mich davon abgehalten, glaube ich, nachhaltig zu rauchen.
Ja, das ist tatsächlich eine gute Frage.
Genau, weil die halt auch diese...
Ja, ja.
Mich hat es abgehalten.
Ich finde auch, verleiht das nicht Leute dazu.
Aber man könnte argumentieren, das ist eine Einstiegsdroge, irgendwie Schokoladenzigaretten.
Irgendwann brauchst du mehr, dann gehst du zu Kaugummi, dann brauchst du mehr, dann gehst du zu Milka.
Dann gehst du zu Milka.
Ja, und dann...
Kaugummi-Zigaretten.
Ich hänge seit Jahren an Milka.
Aber das stimmt. Auch beste Schokolade hat man noch nie. Die besten drei Schokoladensorten? Ich hatte mir nicht die... Ach so. Ja, es ist ein bisschen schwer, weil ich halt keine Schokolade mehr essen kann, aber... Ja gut, aber du weißt ja noch, aus dem Grossteil... Du hast... Jetzt hör... Tu mal nicht so, als ob du seit drei Monaten bist du vegan. Und jetzt tu mal nicht so, als ob du die 90% des Lebens vergessen hast, wie man... Lass uns mal reduzieren auf Rittersport, die besten drei Rittersport. Einfach, weil sonst ist das Thema zu groß. Kommen wir nun zu den Top 3 Rittersport-Sorten. Auf Platz 3, Vollmilch. Ganz basic, Vollmilch, einfach den geballten Schokoladen genutzt. Ich kenne diese Mitarbeiterinnen da überhaupt nicht. Wer ist das denn? Das ist Lea. Nein, die rechte, links. Ach so, das weiß ich nicht, die sehe ich nicht, keine Ahnung. Die Arbeit ist vielleicht nicht hier. Noch eine Lea, wir haben viele Leas hier bei uns, ne? Deswegen sage Dradest du Lea. Bestimmt, bei den Männern kann man immer Julian raten, aber eine Frau nur Lea. Ja, absolut. Also, Platz Nummer drei bei mir, Ritter Sport, ist Joghurt. Ah, ich bin kein Joghurt-Fan. Doch, total.
Ich verstehe das, woher das kommt, aber ich bin kein Joghurt-Fan.
Bei mir auf Platz zwei, Mastipan.
Bei mir auf Platz zwei, Pfefferminz.
Das auch da?
Ich liebe Pfefferminz. Ich weiß, du bist ein After-Eight-Fan.
Ich liebe Pfefferminz, ja.
Hey, Nikolas.
Ah, Nico Berslinger, hallo. Ist zu spät, die haben schon angefangen. Auch auf dem Fahrrad, der komplett perplex, bleibt stehen mit seinem Fahrrad und fährt nicht mehr weiter. Der bleibt stehen, aber kippt auch nicht um. Ganz sehr spannend. Ganz merkwürdige. Bämmer auf Platz 1, Nougat. Und auf Platz Nummer 1 der Rettersportsorten, Knusperflakes. Die gelben? Ja, kenne ich. Bleiben über bei mir. Echt? Nein, das sind die besten. In diesen kleinen Probierpackungen bleiben die über. Nee, nee, nee, die baller ich schön. Genau wie Kaffee und diese ganzen Mockergedöns. Jetzt geht ja bald die Grillsaison wieder los. Mein Tipp für Grillfreunde möchte ich auch mal an den Mann bringen, und zwar die Grillbanane. Die Grillbanane ist ein relativ einfacher Snack für zwischendurch und für den, der auf dem Grillfest vielleicht auch mal was Innovatives mitbringen möchte, der nicht immer auch Nackensteak und Bratwurst. Ja, kein Fleisch mehr. Man weiß auch, wo du argumentativ herkommst. Ja gut, aber wenn du mir weiter zuhören würdest, würdest du sehen, dass auch das völliger Quatsch ist. Denn die Grillbanane, ganz einfach, legt die Grillbanane auf den Grill, so seitlich, dass sie stabil ist, also nicht so aufrecht, sondern seitlich, und schneidet die Grillbanane. Kann man die kaufen, Grillbanane?
Nein, man kauft eine Banane. Ja, weil du das Wort
Grill immer so offensiv davor benutzt. Ja, weil das
Name des Gerichts ist. Also du kaufst eine Banane,
legst sie auf den Grill,
legst sie auf den Grill, schneidest sie
längs auf, durch
bis vor die
zweite Schale, also dass du sie
aufklappen kannst, wie so ein Hotdog, und dann
tust du da Schokolade rein, und dann lässt du die auf den Grill, und dann grillst du die so lange, bis die Schokolade geschmolzen ist und die hast du eine richtig schöne Grillbanane und da kann man auch mal richtig geil experimentieren mit verschiedenen Schokoladensorten. Tut da mal einen Kinderriegel rein, tut da mal Marzipanschokolade rein, tut da mal Nougatschokolade rein, testet einfach mal ein bisschen aus und es wird der Grillspaß für jung und alt. Ne, warum ich eben so lachen musste in meinem Kopf war, dass du das Wort Grill immer davor benutzt, weil ich finde, was wird zu einem Grill XYZ, sobald du es auf den Grill legst, weil Tomate sagst du auch Grill Tomate, man sagt auch Grill Käse, dann habe ich mir gefragt, was ist das für ein Käse, das es dir nicht dazu eignet, Grillkäse genannt zu werden. Einfach nur Käse auf einem Grill. Einfach die Handlung, baut dieses Wort davor, diesen Präfix. Ja, gut. Was ich lustig finde. Also einfach eine lustige, lustige Sache. Ey, ich habe Bock auf die Grillsaison, es wird meine erste vegane Grillsaison und ich bin ja großer Grillfreund, das heißt, ich muss mir da ein paar Sachen überlegen. Toll, das ist auch eine tolle Idee. Ihr müsst mir jetzt gar nicht irgendwelche tollen Rezepte schicken, so Spargel, Aubergine und so. Ja, wir gucken mal. Ist halt auch wie vegan, nee, gar nicht. Nein, unglaublich. Auch interessant, gegrillte Mango möchte ich auch noch mal ganz kurz in den Raum werfen. Tatsächlich, mein großes Ziel ist es ja mal, irgendwann den gegrillten Obstsalat zu etablieren. Gegrillten Obstsalat, schön Banane, Mango, Melone, sowas auf dem Grill, schön ein bisschen anrösten. Grillmelone. Ja, eine Creamie und dann einfach irgendwie schön zusammenwerfen zu einem gegrillten Obstsalat. Probiert das mal aus, Leute. Finde ich nicht schlecht die Idee. Wie sieht für dich ein perfekter Grillabend aus? Also meiner Erfahrung nach bringen alle Schwachsinn mit, ausser ich bringe die besten Sachen mit. Ja, das ist, und ich glaube aus jeder Sicht auch immer so, dass ich die besten Sachen mitbringe. Nein, aber dass man selber immer das Gefühl hat, man isst am liebsten seine Sachen. Und ich bin immer ein bisschen sauer, wenn ich so gute Steaks mitbringe, und dann landen die sich beim anderen auf dem Teller, der nur so einen Obstsalat beigesteuert hat, denke ich mir, nein. Das Allerwichtigste für einen guten Grillabend ist genug Brot. Immer einfach nochmal, weil niemand nimmt Brot mit. Nein, das stimmt nicht. Das ist einfach so. Man verlässt sich immer so auf den Gastgeber. Deswegen einfach nochmal schön zwei Baguettes mitnehmen. Auch wenn am Ende ein Baguette übrig bleibt, ist egal. Du kannst Brot immer noch wegwerfen. Aufgepasst. Aufgemerkt. Das heißt, man kann einfach mitnehmen. Aber ansonsten... Die neue Rubrik. Aufgemerkt. Vielleicht mal tatsächlich zwei ernste-Tipps. Einfach mal Service. Damit einfach die Leute, die gerade irgendwie im ECE feststecken, der sich nicht bewegt, einfach vielleicht nochmal Hunger bekommen. Wie ist Lea jetzt schon wieder auf dem Weg zu? Lea, oh, sie winkt aggressiv zurück. Wie kann das denn sein? Sie ist doch eben, sie ist nicht wieder dahin gegangen. Ganz kurz. Oh Gott, jetzt wird Lea interviewt. Hallo Lea, kurze Frage. Wir haben dich nicht zurückgehen sehen. Du bist jetzt gerade zweimal uns entgegengekommen. Wie ist das möglich? Kannst du durch Wände gehen oder gibt es einen geheimen Gang da hinten hin? Es gibt einen geheimen Gang unter dem Keller. Sehr gut. Oder du musst einfach nachher zweimal zurückgehen, damit es wieder ausgeglichen ist. Ja, ich sage mir das bis Ende der Woche und dann mache ich das. Das ist clever. Da geht es zwei Stunden lang einfach die ganze Zeit zurück. Sehr lustig. Also zwei ernste Grilltipps.
Wupp, wupp, waaaa!
Zwei ernste Grilltipps.
Einerseits die Barbecue-Zwiebel.
Nehmt euch eine Alufo-Schale-Alufolie, also faltet Alufolie...
Eine Schalufolie.
Sehr gut.
Also faltet Alufolie zu so einer Schale, tut da richtig viel Barbecue-Soße rein und dann schneidet eine Zwiebel klein und tut die da rein, verrührt das so ein bisschen, dass es so ein Zwiebel-Barbecue-Matsch ist und grillt den dann einfach. Und durchs Grillen verdampft so ein bisschen die Flüssigkeit der Barbecue-Soße und wird so ein bisschen fester und am Ende hast du so einen richtig schönen Barbecue-Zwiebelschleim und gegrillte, schön saftige Zwiebeln, die man dann auch irgendwie zu Bratwurst auf dem Brötchen tun kann oder irgendwie zu einem Steak dazunehmen kann, so eine Art Relish oder sowas in der Richtung. Richtig schöne, gute Barbecue-Zwiebel. Zweiter Tipp, der Grillfeta. Nehmt euch einen Feta-Käse, diesen Block, tut da einfach ein bisschen Salz, Pfeffer, vielleicht einen Hauch Zitrone, auch Zwiebel und Knoblauch dazu. Packt das alles schön zusammen, alles in Alufolie einpacken. Schön zerlaufen lassen.
Auf dem Grill, schön zerlaufen lassen.
Vorsichtig, für ein paar fünf, sollen wir mal sechs bis acht Minuten anbauen.
Sowas in der Richtung.
Und der Grillfeta mit Grillmango zusammen.
Grill mit Grillpfeffer, mit Grillknoblauch und Grillzitrone.
Mit Grillfreunden und einem Grillgrill und dann ist alles perfekt.
Also viel Spaß mit der Grillsaison, ihr Grillfreunde.
Aufgemerkt, die Grillsaison beginnt.
Aufgemerkt, das Grillformat.
Wir sind noch ein paar Mal da.
Oh, ein gutes Gugnamen für ein Grillformat irgendwie.
Grillbill.
Netflix und Grill.
Sehr gut.
Cross-Promo auch gleichzeitig.
Sehr lustig, mein Lacher der Woche.
Ja.
Neue Rubrik im Podcast UFO, der Lacher der Woche.
Ist nicht alles eine Rubrik. War für mich, wir haben uns diese Woche intensiv über Zahnpasta unterhalten. Und da auch mal ganz kurz, möchte ich kurz deine Meinung nur zu dem Wort Zahnpasta. Ja, ich finde das Wort alles Pasta, Paste, Pastille, auch Salbe, es sind einfach eklatige Dinge, aber Paste und Pasta, das ist so ganz komisch. Pasta ist halt in meinem Kopf wesentlich besser konnotiert. Ja, klar, mit Nudeln, ja. Aber das Ganze ist Paste, ja, es macht keinen Sinn. Aber ich verbinde auch Zahnpasta, habe ich noch nie in meinem Leben mit Pasta in Nudeln verbunden. Nee, gar nicht. Das ist interessant, ne? Es ist exakt dasselbe Wort, exakt selber ausgesprochen. Noch nie verbunden. Keine Verbindung gezogen. Nee. Hat den Gag schon mal jemand gemacht, Zahnpasta, irgendwie so Nudeln, die so aussehen wie Zähne? Der ist, glaube ich, einfach objektiv zu schlecht. Also für Leute ohne Humor. Nee, ist mir noch nie aufgefallen. Zahncreme, aber du sagst schon Zahnpasta. Zahnpasta, ja. Ich habe das Gefühl, dass Zahnpasta irgendwie so ein kindliches Wort ist. Ja, weil da auch so drei As drin sind. Alle Wörter mit drei A's, auch Banane, cool, Banana, direkt Kindwort.
Also sobald du halt drei Vokale einer Sorte hast, ist direkt ein Kindwort.
Also alles drei plus Vokale ist für dich kindlich.
Ja.
Für dich Kafka zwei Vokale.
Nee, drei gleiche Vokale ist für mich kindlich. Probier's mal aus. Was haben wir denn noch?
Ah, Mongo Bongo.
Guantanamo. Guantanamo, ja, Kindwort. Definitiv. Azkaban. Alcatraz, alles Kinder, oder? Wir haben uns über Zahnpasta unterhalten und ich glaube, du hast den, oder irgendjemand hat den sehr lustigen Funfact gebracht, dass Colgate in Spanien ein bisschen Probleme bereitet. Es heißt übersetzt, häng dich auf. Häng dich auf. Colgate ist der Imperativ des Verbs aufhängen und es heißt jeden Morgen und ich finde das so lustig, Colgate, häng dich auf. Wollt ihr weißt, das erste ist, was man morgens macht, das erste Produkt, was man morgens benutzt. Kommt nicht aus dem Bett, Buenasito, Muien Fuego, man geht irgendwie ins Bad und dann, häng dich auf. Und ich finde das so lustig, weil es ist nicht, bring dich um, sondern, häng dich auf. Der praktische Hinweis direkt da mitgeliefert. Das ist so ein konkreter Thema Todesaufforderung. Ich stell mich so vor, wie man durch die Abteilung läuft, im Supermarkt mit den Kindern dabei,
und man hat schon die Brötchen eingepackt. Man braucht noch die Zahnpasta und dann hat man diese gewalte Auswahl davor sich und nimmt man dann die Zahnfixi, Zahnpasta, Denta Med, Denta Spring, nimmt man die Zahnpasti mit dem lustigen kleinen Doktor Pasti da drauf und nimmt man die hänglich auf, Zahnpasta? Hm. Ich weiß nicht. Weil das nichts mit Zahn zu tun. Einfach so, ja, hübsche Zähne, Karies, Zahnstein und by the way, Häng dich auf. Und ich finde das so lustig. Vor allem dann steht ja die Colgate Spain Marketing Abteilung vor der schwierigen Frage. Niemand will da arbeiten. Nehmen wir uns um oder nicht? Oder so, wo arbeitest du? Bei Colgate.
Ah, cool, dankeschön.
Das ist echt...
Ja, vor allem, ich sehe das so dampfende
Köpfe, alle haben so die Hände im Kopf
zusammengeschlagen, einfach in dieser
Marketingabteilung, weil sie seit Jahren will erstens niemand
da arbeiten, ist trotzdem gut bezahlt,
aber niemand will da arbeiten und dann kommen die halt nicht
auf die Erkenntnis, dass sie sich umbenennen sollen.
So stelle ich mir auch immer so vor, wenn man irgendwie eine Komödie zum Beispiel schreibt und man Wortspiele einbaut und man nicht an die ganzen armen Leute denkt, die das übersetzen müssen für andere Länder. Zum Beispiel stell dir jemanden vor, der neben einer Orgel steht und dann sagt, well, und dann seine Orgel verschenkt und dann sagt, I'm an Oregon Donor. Ja Und dann einfach so, Schnitt zu deutscher Übersetzung, einfach drei Leute, die kurz vor der Kündigung stehen,
ich bin ein Orgelspender, Orglanspender, fuck you einfach, vergiss es, müssen wir die Szene rausschneiden, wir können hier einfach Szenen rausschneiden.
Es ist unmöglich zu übersetzen.
Ich finde es im Deutschen teilweise richtig, richtig krass, wie gut man das machen kann. Ja, manchmal schon, manchmal auch gar nicht. Was mich beeindruckt hat, also wirklich massiv beeindruckt hat, wie kann denn das sein, ist bei Family Guy, wo Stewie diesen lustigen, wo Brian diesen lustigen Sprachfehler hat, diese britische Aussprache, glaube ich, ist, wenn er Schlagsahne sagt, cool whip, cool whip und Stewie fragt, ja, sag mal cool, cool, sag mal whip, whip, cool whip, cool whip und es ist lustig und dann habe ich mich aus Spaß meine deutsche Version angehört und ja, sag mal Schlag, Schlag, sag mal Sahne, Sahne, sag mal Schlagsahne, Schlagsahahne. Und es ist wirklich ein Ding, es ist ja wirklich etwas, was existiert. Leute sagen Schlachsahne. Und ich fand das so faszinierend, dass in dem gleichen Wort ebenso sehr der gleich verbreitete Sprachfehler drin ist. Das ist unglaublich. Eine andere Aussprache. Wie wahrscheinlich ist das denn? Das ist so eins in einer Million, glaube ich. Da, glaube ich, sagen die Übersetzer auch einfach Yes. Halleluja. Yes. Und dann tanzen wir erstmal den Übersetzer dann. Aber ansonsten hast du keine Chance. Aber ich fand das so crazy. Aber Colgate, ich glaube, ich muss jetzt immer, wenn ich, ich glaube, ich benutze sogar, nee, ich glaube, ich benutze sogar Colgate manchmal, ich kaufe auch Querbeet einfach. Und ich werde immer daran denken müssen, einfach an diese nette Aufforderung, so mit so einem lächelnden Zahnpassermann, häng dich auf. War mir auch sehr lustig im Lateinunterricht, unser toller Lateinlehrer, auf die Frage, was soll der Scheiss eigentlich, warum lernen wir Latein, hat er gesagt, naja, pass auf, es gibt noch viele lateinische Begriffe in unserem Alltag, die man besser versteht, wenn man Latein lehrt, zum Beispiel die Autofirma Volvo lässt sich übersetzen in Ich walahr. Ich walze alles nieder. Das hat er tatsächlich gesagt und alle so, ja geil, ich walze alles nieder. Wo ist das alles drin? Keine Ahnung. Das heißt einfach, ich fahre. Ja, ich weiß nicht, Volvare, es könnte ja auch sein, dass es sowas wie walzen oder heissen. Ja, aber gut, ich wal ich walze, aber ich walze alles nieder.
Wo ist das alles drin, wo ist das nieder, frage ich mich. Aber so hat es uns ein Lateinlehrer übersetzt, der gesagt hat, ja, Volvo zum Beispiel heißt, ich walze alles nieder, auch ich persönlich, ich, nicht irgendwie mein Auto oder wir, sondern ich walze alles nieder. Welches Auto hätten Sie gerne? Ein, kommt von dem Herrn Horch, Audi, oder BMW vielleicht, oder ich walze alles nieder. Nö, ich will schon das Auto von ich walze alles nieder. Ich hab auch so, wenn man so eine so unterdrückte Machtwille hat, einfach dann direkt zu Volvo greifen. Das finde ich clever.
Ich walze alles nieder.
Wurde Mercedes nach der Tochter des Besitzes des Finders. Aber mittlerweile werden alle Leute, die Mercedes heißen, alle Frauen, nach der Marke Mercedes benannt. Das stimmt. Oder gibt es eine Göttin oder irgendwie sowas. Vice versa. Hat sich alles gedreht. Die Autogöttin.in. Das finde ich auch so, dass es ja irgendwie so,
und so Gangster-Rappern und so in so einem Gangster-Milieu
auch immer so Autos als Status-Nombole sehr wichtig sind.
Es gibt auch bestimmt viele Rapsongs, wo das Wort Mercedes drin ist,
was halt, wenn es nicht ein Autor wäre, einfach ein Mädchenvorname wäre,
wie Annika.
So, dann würden halt Hardcore-Rapper, die irgendwie,
ich wurde schon dreimal angeschossen, rappen über Annika.
Die Firma könnte genauso gut Annika, nichts gegen Annika,
Aber eigentlich ist es ein sehr guter, wenn man sich mal vorstellt, über wen Leute eigentlich singen. Weil wir haben immer so eine romantische Vorstellung über, angenommen wenn Adele eine schöne Ballade singt, über ihren Traummann oder so, dann stellt man sich ja immer so einen, weiss ich nicht, einfach so einen sehr attraktiven Mann vor, der dann irgendwie in so einem Sakko da steht, sie begrüsst, sie einlädt, zur Bar, was zu trinken geht. Wahrscheinlich, ich meine, sie ist jetzt nicht die Dünste, mittlerweile kann sie jeden haben, kurz Fettshaming, wahrscheinlich singt sie über einen ganz fetten, stinkenden, ekligen Typen. Ja. Und ich meine, ich finde diese Freundin immer so lustig, dass man das immer so im Kopf so romantisiert. Wahrscheinlich hat sie einfach einen ganz komischen Männergeschmack. Ja, vor allem wenn dieser Typ zurückkommen würde aus Someone Like You, über den sie nicht hinweggekommen ist, sondern zurückkommt und ist halt irgendwie so ein abelslose Fernfahrer Mitte 40 und Adele die Mega Queen unendlich reich, dann sagt so, nee, pass auf, dann singt der erst Someone like you. Genau, dann wird er noch berühmter und dann geht es immer so hin und her. Ja, und irgendwann sind es die Weltstars einfach. Ich habe eben gedacht, ich finde, die christliche Religion lässt sich relativ gut auf die Neuzeit übertragen. Du hast halt so ein Gott für alles. Das hilft, glaube ich, einfach der Kirche zu sagen, okay, er ist immer noch überall, das passt, das ist alles übertragbar. Aber diese ganzen spezifischen Götter, gerade die griechischen Götter zum Beispiel, oder die römischen, wo man sagt, die haben, es gibt den Gott des Streitwagens, der Streitwagen-Kämpfe, Wettkämpfe. Wie genau wird das übertragen? Ich meine, das sind ja sehr spezielle Götter für sehr spezielle Situationen. Ja, das stimmt schon. Das ist schon ziemlich komisch. Aber es ist interessant, dass sich anscheinend die monotheistischen Religionen weitestgehend komplett durchgesetzt haben gegen politistische Religionen. Ungewöhnlich, also warum sind die so krass überlegen? Da hat sich bestimmt mal jemand mit beschäftigt. Ja, vor allem ist es Doktorarbeit, Religionswissenschaft. Prinzip Sammelkarten. In meinem Kopf ist es immer spannender, man will ja auch individuell sein, man will seinen eigenen Gott anbeten. Ich finde es ganz cool, einfach mehrere Leute zu haben. Es ist, glaube ich, einfach verwirrend. Es ist, glaube ich, ein kleines Beispiel, aber ich habe auch einen DSR-Podcast und in der Welt von DSR, einem Pen-and-Paper-Rollenspiel, gibt es auch zwölf Götter. Und wir behandeln in diesem Podcast auch jeden einzelnen dieser Götter. Und auch wenn es alles albern ist und Spaß und nerdig und so, wir tun uns manchmal wirklich schwer damit, theologisch das zu fassen, wie das jetzt aussehen soll an zwölf verschiedene Götter mit zwölf verschiedenen Aspekten, die sich auch teilweise ein bisschen widersprechen. Also es gibt dann den Gott der Gerechtigkeit und den Gott der Diebe. So, das ist dann so, ja gut, aber ihr seid beide Götter, die beide Wahrheit haben. Also das ist so ein bisschen schwierig, wo man sich denkt, es ist einfach verwirrend und es ist schwer zu fassen. Es gibt Gottes Friedens und es gibt Gottes Krieges, Mars. Ja, absolut, ja. Und dann denke ich mir auch so, wow, wow, wow, Mars, also es ist sehr einfach, ein radikaler Grieche zu sein. Also vor allem, weil alles damit vereinbar ist. Es gibt Gottes Krieges. Ich meine, die Religion liefert keine Werte mit. Jetzt haben sie ja beides geht noch Religionen durchgesetzt, die ein gewisses Wertepaket mitliefern. Ja, und vor allem in den griechischen Mythologien kann man ja tatsächlich so ein bisschen sehen, dass die sich von dem menschlichen Verhalten her leiten. Also Götter sind auch eifersüchtig und auch fehlerhaft und bauen auch Scheiss. Die wollen halt auch einfach nur Sex und so. Und dann merkt man so, ah, die sind relativ nah an dem tatsächlichen Menschen und nicht an der Idealvorstellung irgendwie. Deswegen ist es vielleicht auch einfach verwirrend und zu nah vielleicht, zu echt. Oder vielleicht war es auch besser. Es ist nicht so weit weg von Power Rangers oder so. Alle haben ihre eigenen Optiken. Das ist vielleicht, ich stelle mir auch richtig cool vor. Jeder hat sein eigenes Tier, sein eigenes Zeichen. Ich bin Mars, Gott des Krieges, ich bin Venus, Gott der Liebe, weiß ich gerade nicht. Aber das ist schon ganz cool. Ich stelle mir richtig cool vor, die jungen Griechen haben bestimmt einfach coole Poster in ihrem Zimmer. Coole Poster von coolen Göttern. Ey, bist du Team Mars? Ne, ich bin Team... Ju, bitte. Ich überlege gerade, ob Mars und Venus zusammenpassen oder ob das nicht römische und griechische Mythologie ist. Aber ich glaube, es passt ja dann, weil du hast noch Ares und Aphrodite. Aber ich bin mir nicht sicher. Ja, ja, ich bin mir auch gar nicht sicher. Ares ist aber auch so ein Kriegstyp, ne?
Ja, genau, das ist ja der, glaube ich, dann der römische.
Papst ist römische Pornbau.
Nicht der griechische, aber ich bin mir nicht sicher, verwechsel das immer.
Ja, gut.
Ach Mensch, Leute, das ist immer so mein Ding, ich verwechsel das.
Apropos Religion, der Humorkongress.
Yay!
Ihr habt uns geflutet, ihr habt uns darauf hingewiesen, Humorkongress in Basel findet im September statt und wir haben es getan, sind da, bei, wir haben es geschafft, ich habe gestern 290 Euro an den Humorkongress Basel, an eine Privatfrau, die ist offensichtlich organisiert, überwiesen, alles cool, wir sind eingetütet, wir sind einen kompletten Tag, inklusive zwei Workshops, die wir fein selber nicht ausgewählt haben an diesem einen Tag. Sind wir da, wir sind in Basel. Ich kann es nicht fassen, wir reisen nach Basel, wir sind im Humorkongress, was wir letztes Jahr nicht geschafft haben. Also ich glaube die dritte Folge von Podcast UFO on Tour, nachdem wir in Hamburg waren und in New York waren, kommt jetzt Basel, schon das dritte Land, das wir bereisen. Wow, in der Schweiz, es wird unglaublich. Wir werden natürlich versuchen, da auch ein paar Folgen aufzunehmen, die Experten natürlich zu interviewen, mal so ein paar richtige Humormaschinen auch mal zu haben, die sich jeden Tag mit Humor beschäftigen. Ich brauche bis dahin so ein Reporter-Mikrofon, was man so mitnimmt, wenn man auch so Radiobeiträge macht. Ja, und dann auch mal die Besucher befragen. Ja, auch mal mit Einspielern. Wir müssen auch mal mit Einspielern arbeiten. Weißt du, wir nehmen das langsam so ein bisschen alles gegeben. Wir müssen mal wieder ein bisschen was tun. Wir müssen jetzt mal ein bisschen mehr Content anführen. Ja, da hast du völlig recht. So einen schönen Beitrag mal, so einen schönen Radiobeitrag. Mal den Zuschauer abholen. Oder mal ein Lied zwischendurch singen. Ja. Du holst deine Gitarre raus. Oder mal einfach so den Clown-Workshop so ein bisschen mitverfolgen. Ja, genau. Einfach mal so ein bisschen so Rap-in-Gefahr-Style. So, mein Name ist Stefan, ich bin heute beim Clown-Workshop und wir schauen uns mal rein. Dann viel Spaß und dann kommt so eine lustige Musik, da stehen auch vielleicht Filme, dann mit so lustigen Video-Effekten, wie ich dann schneller in den Raum gehe und so wie man das alles so kennt. Zeitrafferaufnahmen. Ja, auf jeden Fall gut. Wir werden versuchen, das medial so gut es geht auszuschlachten. Wir sind nur einen Tag da, wir versuchen aber auch rauszuballen. Ist aber auch sauteuer. Aber das ist zum Beispiel mal da auch nochmal vielen Dank natürlich an alle Leute, die uns über Patreon unterstützen. Das könnt ihr immer tun, weil damit ist sowas möglich und damit können wir uns sowas leisten, auch mal einen Tag irgendwie in fremde Länder zu reisen und einfach mal das Humormecker Basel zu besuchen. Ich meine, wenn man an Humor denkt, denke ich an New York, ich denke an Los Angeles und ich denke an Basel. Das sind die grossen Humorzentren der Welt. Ich habe vor, Gags zu opfern, ich werde dort mindestens zehn Gags opfern, ich werde im Stand-Up-Gebet, werde ich mich vertiefen, um einfach mal auch meinen Humor zu reinigen, einfach mal zu sehen, was sind so die dunklen Ecken, was muss weg, was kann erneuert werden. Einfach so eine Selbstfindung, so eine Humoristische Selbstfindung. Ich habe wirklich überlegt, im Sommer mal eine Woche nach Tibet zu reisen. Einfach mal so nach Tibet. In so ein Mönchskloster. Das ist halt, man hört das häufig in Filmen, dass dann Leute Urlaub machen oder so. Kann man da wirklich Urlaub machen? Meine Mutter macht regelmäßig Urlaub in Tibet, aber es ist, glaube ich, nicht so leicht, weil Tibet ist ja besetzt von China und die verstehen keinen Spaß und du brauchst da verschiedene Wiesen, Wisas, Wiese, um da reinzukommen und es ist möglich, also meine Mutter schafft es, aber ich glaube, es ist nicht so leicht. Also ich glaube, du kannst nicht sagen, ich hätte gerne ein Reisebüro und nächste Woche wäre ich gerne in Tibet. Aber wenn du das verfolgst mit Ehrgeiz, dann kannst du das auch schaffen. Aber ich glaube nicht, dass du das tun wirst, sondern einfach nichts tust. Du kannst einfach in eine Sauna gehen und dich da entspannen. Naja, ich will mich nicht entspannen, ich will halt die ganze Kultur atmen. Geh auf den Berg, dann fahr in die Alpen. Ich will mit diesen glasköpfigen Mönchen sprechen, telepathisch, ich will Superkräfte wie Dr. Strange lernen. Du willst ja nur so eine Klangschale haben. Ja, ich will so eine Klangschale, ich will so einen Gong haben. Ich lasse auch so ein paar Bücher mitgehen aus ihren heiligen Bibliotheken. So war es halt. Stefan ist ja ein bisschen, naja, einsam geworden, nachdem sein Lieblingsfisch Jeff gestorben ist. Und ich habe letztens mit Stefan mich unterhalten über das Thema und er hat ernsthaft in Erwägung gezogen, ein neues Haustier sich zu besorgen. Er hat über ein kleines Kätzchen nachgedacht, ein Hundewelpen. Wir sind Humorprofis. Wenn man dann privat redet, man kommt ja nicht so raus und dann sagt man mal ein paar unüberlegte Dinge und man macht mal ein paar Scherze und ich habe vielleicht den Satz gesagt, ich denke ernsthaft darüber nach. Ich weine mich jeden Tag in den Schlaf. Und ich habe ernsthaft überlegt, mir eine Katze zu holen. Habe ich vielleicht gesagt, und auch da abgesehen, dass es unmöglich ist, weil ich eine massive Katzenhaarallergie habe. Es ist aber trotzdem das Prinzip Katze. Ich gucke es mir gerne an. Ich spiele sehr gerne das Szenario durch, wenn ich mir jetzt eine Katze holen würde, wie würde ich es machen und gucke mir dann halt so ein paar Rassen an und ich bin halt sehr begeisterungsfähig und manchmal trickse ich mich aus, indem ich mich genauso, Stichwort Boot, manchmal denke ich mir, wow, wie cool wäre es, ein Boot zu haben und dann gucke ich mir einfach, dann shoppe ich im Internet nach Booten und ich shoppe miteinander Katzen und gucke dann halt so, was wäre die beste Katze für mich, utopischerweise wird es nicht für die funktionieren, aber einfach um das mal, und man eignet sich sehr viel Wissen an auch, weil ich weiß jetzt genau, welche Katze zu wem passt. Und je nachdem, was für Bedürfnisse man hat und wie oft man zu Hause ist und wie viel man mit Katzen machen will, kann ich jetzt die Leute Katzen beraten und Bote. Meine Mitbewohnerin hat eine Katze und ich bin heute Morgen aufgewacht und hatte Katzenstreu im Bett. Das sind oft so die Seiten, die solche Katzenvideos ausklammern. Ja, wenn du ein wirklich richtig guter Katzenpapa sein willst, dann musst du damit rechnen, dass Katze haben auch nicht immer nur Sonnenschein und Kuscheln ist. Nee, die pinkelt dir auch manchmal ins Bett oder in eine Schublade. Flotendienst war ein toller Moment. Auf irgendeinem Grund hast du plötzlich Katzenstreu im Bett. Du weißt nicht, ist das benutzt, ist das frisch, wie hat die das transportiert? Keine Ahnung. Aber man muss sich vorstellen, solche Fragen stellt man sich. Stell dir mal vor, Florentin, ihr arbeitet mit Florentin plötzlich, kriegt dann eine Meldung. Ah, ein Paket ist für dich da. Ein Paket für dich da, cool. Er springt auf, euphorisch, Tränen in den Augen, rennt los, kommt mit einem grossen Paket wieder. Ich denke mir, wow, auch schön für ihn, er hat sich was besorgt. Was ist es, ein neues Buch, ist es vielleicht ein tolles Spielzeug, ist es eine Konsole, was bringen seine Augen so zum Leuchten? Er macht das Paket auf, reißt es wie ein Kind an Weihnachten auf und drinnen sind einfach so Bottiche, so grosse Kanister voller Katzenurin-Geruchsentferner.
Und seine Augen strahlten. Ich dachte mir, okay,
das ist der Weg, den du jetzt einschlagen willst.
Gerne. Okay, wir
unterstützen dich dabei.
Ich habe dich noch nie so glücklich gesehen
und danach auch noch nie so ausgeschlafen,
weil ich glaube, das hat wirklich dein Leben massiv verbessert.
Auf jeden Fall.
Und das heißt irgendwie so Bactodent
oder sowas in der Richtung. Das ist richtig gut, weil da sind so Bakterien drin in diesem Spray und man kann das so aussprühen dahin, wo die Katze hingepinkelt hat. Und das ist richtig gut, weil die Bakterien fressen irgendwie die anderen Bakterien auf. Die fressen auch dich ein bisschen, aber das ist egal. Ein bisschen ja, aber es ist, und das ist schon sehr, sehr gut, aber es ist wirklich eine Erleichterung. Und auch einfach zu wissen, du hast was in der Hinterhand und du bist halt einfach nicht verloren, wenn deine Katze in deinem Bett pinkelt und du kannst halt einfach nicht die ganze Nacht schlafen.
Du kannst was dagegen tun, ist auf jeden Fall gut. Es ist nicht so toll, wenn du ein Problem hast und es gibt eine exakte Lösung dafür. Ja, genau das. Ich finde das so geil. Es gibt also genau das Problem, hatten auch andere dutzendfach, so dutzendfach, dass es Leute gab, die sich eine Taskforce gegründet haben und ein Produkt dagegen entwickelt haben. Nur dagegen. Ich finde das so geil, dass du ... Weil oft haben wir ja Probleme, die sind undurchsichtig. Gerade auch als komplexe Menschen mit komplexen Problemen kann man manchmal nicht einfach so sagen, okay, das ist die Lösung für mein Problem, sondern du musst halt an dir arbeiten, wochenlang, um auf die Gedanken zu kommen, die dir helfen, etwas zu überstehen. Aber ich weiß nicht, ob das so ... Ich kann gerade ein bisschen verzweifeln, aber es ist doch geil, wenn du halt ein Problem hast, was du einfach so mit dem Fingerzeigen. Und du merkst auch irgendwie, dass du auf dem richtigen Weg bist. Das ist wie wenn du in einem Videospiel eine Tür kommst und du weißt nicht, wie die Tür aufmachst, oder dann merkst du, ich habe im Inventar genau den Schlüssel, den ich brauche, und du weißt, hier geht das Spiel definitiv weiter. Ich bin auf dem richtigen Weg, und so ist es im Alltag auch, wenn du irgendwie ein Problem hast, deine Scheibe vom Auto ist eingefroren und du hast diesen Scheibenkratzer und du weißt wow, du bist auf dem richtigen Weg. Weil sobald du halt dieses Gefühl hast, dass etwas für dich gemacht wurde, hast du das Gefühl, genau gerade an dem richtigen Ort zu sein, der für dich bestimmt ist, weil es wurde ja was für dich gemacht. Das ist eine ganz, ganz blöde Sicht auf die Dinge, aber es hilft einem einfach so, damit klarzukommen, dass man gerade am richtigen Ort ist, glaube ich. Auf jeden Fall. Und dass ihr am richtigen Ort seid, wisst ihr, wenn dieser Podcast gleich aufhört. Ehrlich jetzt schon? Zurück in euer Leben geworfen werdet. Das fand ich ganz toll, dass man sich nicht anguckt, sondern immer nach vorne guckt, auf so eine tolle freie Fläche. Der Podcast ist vorbei, jetzt seid ihr gefragt, macht auch einen eigenen Podcast. Macht das jetzt nicht jede Woche. Ich habe letztes Woche beim Schneiden das Ende gehört. Selbst ich hatte Angst und ich habe auch was gesagt. Ich habe gesagt, jetzt seid ihr dran, es geht eure Show los. Und dann dachte ich mir so, wow, dieser Druck, den man plötzlich verspürt. Nein, weißt du was, Unterhaltung ist das Zentrum des Lebens. Immer wenn ihr einen schlechten Tag habt oder so, es gibt ganz viele Leute, die für euch Unterhaltung machen, es gibt tolle Serien, es gibt tolle Filme.
Kümmeret euch nicht um eure Probleme, sondern guckt euch diese Sachen an, die dafür da sind, das Leben des modernen Menschen erträglich zu machen.
Und ihr habt immer etwas, auf das ihr euch freuen könnt. Dafür ist gesorgt mittlerweile. Und guckt euch eine schöne Serie an. Das ist meine Botschaft jetzt an euch.
Ablenkung, Ablenkung, Ablenkung. Bis zum nächsten Mal bei Podcasts Ufe. Macht's gut. Ciao.